hello and welcome, i'm james murphy
and today i'm going to show you why
every proof that you've seen
of the fact that 0.99 repeating equals 1 is wrong.
don't worry, it IS true.
this isn't one of those videos,
it's just the proofs that
you've seen that are wrong
so first i'll show you why
those other proofs are wrong,
and then i'll show you my actual proof.
the vast majority of proofs that .99 repeating
equals one are so-called algebraic proofs
they start with some number,
they do some algebraic manipulations,
and then they somehow derive that one
is equal to 0.99 repeating from that.
these are by far the most common kind of
proof that you'll see when you look it up
and at first glance they look pretty sensible.
i start with x being 0.99
repeating then i multiply by 10,
i subtract x and then i solve for
x equals 1. seems valid right?
we all know a third is 0.33 repeating,
multiply by 3 and then we get
1 is 0.99 repeating, right?
well it turns out there are
multiple mistakes in these proofs.
well right at the very start we've
actually made a huge mistake.
just by writing 0.99 repeating, i'm
implicitly assuming that it exists.
if .99 repeating didn't exist
then i wouldn't be able to
multiply it by 10 and then solve for it.
this is the error that pretty
much every video makes.
i've only seen one that doesn't make this mistake.
let me show you what can go wrong in
a very similar situation by making
this assumption that it does exist.
instead of looking at 0.99 repeating,
let's look at a very similar expression.
let's suppose that a number 9 repeating
and then the point exists.
so i'm thinking here as the decimal point
with nines extending out on the left side
of it instead of on the right side of it.
i start with 9 repeating, i multiply by
10, i add 9, and i see that i end up back
with the number that i started with.
so then i can solve for that
algebraically and i get that x is minus 1.
pause the video and check the steps if you want.
so do you believe that 9 repeating point
is equal to negative one?
well no you really shouldn't.
there are number systems where this kind of thing
is true, but the real numbers is not one of them.
okay so suppose you're willing to believe
that it does exist as a real number
then the rest of the proof works right?
well still no. so what's wrong? is it one
of the highlighted green statements?
which one of those is wrong?
well, none of them.
all of those statements are true.
they're true because .99 repeating is equal
to one, but these proofs don't show it.
you have to keep in mind that
a proof of something is not
simply a list of true statements that
ends in the one that you're looking for.
i can't just say "one plus one equals
two" "two plus two equals four"
"the fundamental theorem of calculus holds"
these are all true statements, but this is not
a proof of the fundamental theorem of calculus.
you need to show why each step implies the next.
since the rules of algebra are so well known ,
in algebraic proofs it's very common to
leave off this reasoning.
but for now, let me make
those implications explicit.
so in this slide i'm using this "implies" arrow
to indicate that each line implies the next line.
i claim that the issue with these
proofs lies in these arrows,
not in the statements themselves.
--these red arrows specifically.
look at the first step on the left.
i multiply 0.99 repeating by 10
and i end up with 9.99 repeating.
now, for ordinary finite
decimal expansion numbers,
we know that multiplying by 10 is the same as
just moving the decimal point one to the right.
but how do we know that that
holds for repeated decimals?
after all you could never finish the
computation of multiplying it out.
now again this IS true,
you are allowed to do this.
but we haven't justified why in this proof.
the reason that you're allowed to is
actually a fact from calculus, not algebra.
now, while this step is fine if
you're familiar with calculus,
it's essentially just pushing
a constant inside a limit,
the general population that would be
interested in answering this question
"is 0.99 repeating equal to 1?"
we can't assume that they know that.
if we just use that fact, i think
we're kind of doing them a disservice
because it doesn't really answer their question.
all we've really done is hidden the details
in another thing that they don't understand.
the problem with the red arrow
on the right is pretty similar,
how do i know that multiplying .33 repeating
times three actually gives .99 repeating?
and as long as we're on
the topic of hiding details
in places you don't understand,
why are you so okay with one-third
being exactly equal to 0.33 repeating?
that sounds kind of just as hard to
prove as 0.99 repeating is equal to 1.
people seem a lot more okay with that one,
but i don't really think you should be.
okay let's start working towards an actual proof.
first let's address what i think is the
real source of your confusion:
the definition of 0.99 repeating.
what does .99 repeating actually mean?
it is definitely NOT some kind of mystical number
with infinitely many nines
after the decimal point.
that's not a definition.
you have to give a definition
in terms of things that are already understood.
so here's how we actually define 0.99 repeating.
we start by defining a sequence.
the first element of the sequence is 0.9,
then 0.99, then 0.999 and so on,
where the nth term in the sequence
is just point followed by n 9's.
you can write it for an arbitrary n using
this capital sigma fancy math notation,
but that's not really necessary.
remember that for a fixed value of n,
this is just a finite decimal approximation.
it has n digits after the
decimal point and it stops.
the definition of 0.99 repeating is just
the number that this sequence approaches,
if there is such a number.
in mathematical terms we
say that it is the limit of the sequence,
but it's okay if you're not familiar with limits.
just think "it's the number
that this sequence approaches".
so let's get back to the original question.
what is ".99 repeating equals one" even claiming?
all it's saying is that this
sequence 0.9 0.99 0.999 and so on
is approaching a real
number, and that number is 1.
well isn't that obvious? you already knew that!
here's a plot of the first
few terms of the sequence
you can see that it's definitely
going to one pretty quickly.
so at this point do i even
really need to give a proof
now that you understand what this
statement is actually claiming?
it doesn't seem so mystical anymore, does it?
what it's actually claiming
is just pretty mundane.
but i did say that i will give
a real proof so here it is.
all we have to show is that that sequence of
0.9999 approximations is
getting closer and closer to 1.
okay so let's just look at the
difference xn - 1 in absolute value.
plug in the expression for xn and you see that
that difference is 10 to the minus n,
or 1 over 10 to the n if you prefer.
i think a lot of people would be
comfortable stopping there and saying
"okay yeah i see that this goes to zero"
but if you really want to finish the argument
and give the formal definition, then okay.
give me some tolerance epsilon bigger than 0,
then i say well for any n that's
bigger than 1 over epsilon,
we see that that difference is 10 to the minus n,
which is less than 1 over n,
which is less than epsilon,
and that's how you would formally
show that the sequence approaches one.
but of course you already knew that!
so i hope that really clears things
up for you, so you don't have that
irky feeling in your stomach when you
see one of those algebraic proofs and
still don't really feel
satisfied with the conclusion.
all the real hard work is just in understanding
the definition and once you understand that,
i think it clears right up.
and i do want to address one last thing.
i know that a lot of videos
phrase this as a choice.
what should we choose .99 repeating to be?
and that is completely fair,
you can take the symbols and define
them to mean whatever you want.
but notice that this whole process
of defining a repeating decimal
didn't really depend on using 0.99.
the real choice here that mathematicians made
was not that .99 repeating equals one. the
actual thing that mathematicians decided on was:
what does it mean to add up
an infinite number of things?
so in that sense, we didn't choose
the value of 0.99 repeating to be 1.
we chose the definition of an infinite sum,
and then from that we were able to
derive the value of 0.99 repeating.
and the last thing that i want to
talk about is all those other videos.
now if you just looked at the title of
this video, you might think i'm trying
to start some kind of flame war,
which i'm definitely not.
i think that each of those videos
is worth watching, and you can learn
something from each and every one of them.
i just felt like none of those videos really
fully removed the source of confusion.
so that's the real reason that
i wanted to make this video.
just to clear things up for you the viewer.
i do want to give a special shout out to
the mathematical association of america.
their video was the only one that i found
that didn't assume that .99 repeating
exists, and i stole one of the
examples in this video from theirs.
hey everyone that's all i've got on this
topic so thank you for watching! if you
liked the video please consider subscribing,
sharing with your friends and, as always,
slap that like button an odd number of times.
see you next time